a hundred episodes of marriage boot camp
we're celebrating tonight what is a
lesson you learn from your time on the
show that you still apply in your
marriage
our biggest lesson is that we need to
mate even though we think it should be
all about our kids and our family we
have to make time for a relationship and
for ourselves to have a healthy family
life very easy to get caught up in
everyday life
kids kids kids kids you got it you got
to stop break focus on each other well
you're having a parents night out
tonight
a little bachelor like double triple
date there's a few couples here
can we talk about bachelor nation I want
to get into Kaitlyn Bristowe just made
some explosive comments about Mike
Fleiss what did you think she called him
a piece of who hates women
what's your response to that I have no
response because I don't know I don't
know him well at all I mean really did
you know what we read and can't judge
people based upon that alone so kind of
said at all kind of a shocking comment
to make she also said she felt like he
blocked her from doing Dancing with the
Stars which I think is part of that did
you ever have discussions for Dancing
with the Stars you know I love to dance
and that would be my dream to go on but
I never ever had a discussion it's
interesting though why it was Trista was
the only one and then
let's right now but a lot about your
rent a lot of bachelors but never not a
lot of bachelorettes so I'm I do wonder
why my question for the ABC execs we'll
ask them one day pilot Pete injured
while filming the show did you guys ever
have any experience like that where
production had to like halt because
something like that one down I was sick
one day on my birthday so we had to just
like shut down filming for one day but
that was it but no that's crazy but I
can see how that would happen I mean
they're doing stunts like crazy things
like
venturous activity he's like I could see
how something could go wrong
pretty uneventful for us I mean me and
my producer on the Scott went missing
and a Taiwanese massage parlor I am not
joking like I was like this is happening
like we are gonna go missing I have a
different Taiwanese massage parlor story
than that but human-trafficking story
and then something else well we'll leave
that there the show has changed a lot
even since you guys were on it the
contestants are getting younger and
younger but we get we get married
we got married older and older so do you
think the show should still end in a
proposal really like good questions but
they're there they're like that's with a
lot of things that we can talk about
that are like too hot for this
microphone right now I think you have to
do what feels right like for us it felt
right I never thought well from at the
time it felt right looking back like
what the hell was I thinking proposing
on after two months but but you got to
do what feels right I mean
no one forces you to do anything so so
but the thing is really interesting
because it just goes to show people are
not settling down younger there they're
just looking for something so maybe they
people are that are going on the show
now it's like they don't have the same
intentions that people did five years
ago or like now there's platforms that
people are kind of building their whole
careers on so it's like things are
changing people leave these shows now
with hundreds if not millions of
followers what advice you have people
who are entering the world like that
it's different from how you guys left
the show we left the show like we
weren't even allowed to use social media
for a while I mean I think just be true
to yourself and you know I'm happy and
I'm happy for other people that can make
things you know if it better is their
life and it brings more experiences to
them I think that's great I really do
why not
is there anything when you watch the
show that you think they should change
about the series or the format now that
time has evolved what do I know right
they do have a magic formula it's like
watching more and more people are
watching than ever
Tyler Cameron is single again should he
and Hannah give it a shot in the real
world the gigi hadid intrigued by their
interaction on the after I was like oh
yeah they're going to dates
I'm into it yeah he's like but the thing
is he's been kind of like sexy cool and
she's a little more goofy I don't know
are they a match I don't know he's crazy
sexy cool like me I'm sexy
[Music]
[Applause]